російська церква - Це не про релігію
поскольку вы возглавляете Владимир
васильвич росгвардию то я хотел бы чтобы
этот образ именно был в рядах росгвардии
Российской Федерации и Победа будет за
нами А эта икона будет защищать русское
воинство російська церква є частиною
російського ж механізму агресії і
пропаганди це як такі щупальця які
оплутують українське суспільство роблять
із прихожан слухняних адептів Русского
Мира чому Путін почав війну проти
України Ну это не Путин начал до Путіна
Як ставитись А как же это это наш
правітель и святейший Патриарх
украинской державы нет И не будет саме
тому за часів Петра Порошенка дуже
активно проводилась якраз лінія на
відрізання цього щупальця саме тому
українським православним допомо могли
отримати томос тому що він заклав
найголовніше основу для того щоби
існувала українська церква яка буде
визнана світовим православ'ям і яка
дозволить всім православним в Україні
об'єднатися в своїй українській церкві а
не шукати Бога в церкві російській На
жаль російська церква продовжує
обстоювати лінію на те що вона не
збирається е ніяким чином виконувати
закони України вона не збирається
виконувати закон України ще від 18-го
року про те що ім'я російської церкви
має бути чесно сказане людям вони
обдурюють вони роблять якісь позірні
зміни в статут коли вона акуратно
вимирала все те що стосується ніби
цивільної частини справи але так само
старанно залишила найголовніше що
стосується прямого духовного зв'язку з
російською православною церквою там
написано чорним по-білому що вона діє
відповідно до грамоти Московського
патріархале Олексія I А там в свою чергу
чорном по-білому написано що УПЦ МП
сполучена з усім православям через
російську православну церкву для
будь-кого Хто знає Навіть базово канони
це означає УПЦ таки МП вона є частиною
рпц а все інше - це будь-які юридичні
форми які можуть бути там відповідно до
моменту змінені перемінені і таке інше
тому постало питання що
необхідно остаточно законодавчо
заборонити існування російської
православної церкви в Україні разом з
усіма її структурними підрозділами Саме
так структурний підрозділ називається
всі церкви поза межами Російської
Федерації які входять в систему
російської Православної Церкви оцей
структурний підрозділ в Україні так само
існувати не повинен російська церква в
Україні має бути заборонена це питання
нашої національної безпеки це найбільша
громадська організація яка напряму
підпорядковується гундяєву і Кремлю ще в
листопаді минулого року європейською
солідарністю було запропоновано
законопроект
8221 в якому якраз передбачалося дуже
чітко сказати Московська церква її
структурні підрозділи в Україні не
можуть діяти всі питання в православному
світі мають вирішуватися відповідно до
томосу наданого вселенським патріархам
Ну але чомусь вирішили
що ініціативи європей
солідарності не має права на просування
і Влада вирішила іти своїм шляхом було
ціле рішення Ради національної безпеки і
оборони на його виконання було висунуто
Урядовий законопроект і Урядовий
законопроект передбачає кілька кроків
Кожен з яких може на жаль затягнути на
місяці Якщо не на
роки викорінення Московської церкви цей
закон передбачає що спочатку проводиться
релігіознавча експертиза На жаль її
можна оскаржити в суді а Суд не має
ліцензованих експертів в цій сфері як і
не має методик це затягнеться на роки
потім подається припис який потрібно
виконати але припис не є обов'язковим до
виконання і теж може бути предметом
оскарження після цього якщо припис не
виконується можна йти в суди і судитися
в цих судах 10 років так як робила
заборонена ще в 14-му році Комуністична
партія А за цей шлях Вони шукають
лазівки то якісь так звані незалежні
громади реєструють то розказують що це
не про них і вони там ще якісь зміни в
статут внесуть а значить мовляв у них
зовсім інший підхід має бути Тому о так
як написано не годиться добре що пройшло
в першому читанні бо це краще ніж нічого
але до другого треба дуже ретельно
допрацювати по-перше експертизи вже є на
них можна посилатися друге щодо приписів
є питання того що держава має чітко
сказати що не може бути Московської
церкви і її структурних підрозділів в
Україні і це теж треба вносити в
законопроект європейська Солідарність
виступає послідовно у всіх місцевих
громадах щоби ті особливо історичні
будівлі які зараз в оренді в
безкоштовному користуванні і таке інше у
московських попів були передані назад
громаді далі вже би вирішувалося питання
чи вони передаються до православної
церкви України в використання і таке
інше ми маємо зробити закон який буде
ефективним виконуватися негайно захищати
національну безпеку і заборонить ні не
українську церкву але він заборонить
будь-якій українській церкві слухатися
гундяєва підпорядковуватися Москві
вбивати українських людей ми ж чули всі
аргументацію що мовляв немає голосів в
слузі народу дуже дорогі московські попи
для багатьох в слугах народу Ми там
бачили як бігали різні Там впливові і не
дуже депутати або переконанням або
прокльонами або матюками намагаючись
відрадити від
голосування
один і ми розуміємо що дуже далеко
пустили щупальця ці якраз московські
попи в Уми дуже багатьох тих хто власне
представляє слугу народу в парламенті
украї православна церква історична є
церквою Київської Русі ми є нащадками
Київської Русі великої України Так
сталася це історія далі Що буде дуже
серйозна робота бо я розповів про ті
правки які ми будемо обстоювати але є
правки Які в протилежному напрямку бо
оці от адепти Московської церкви вони
розказують А давайте туди Запишемо що
тільки ті які мають організаційне
сполучення з центром в Москві пам'ятаємо
такі прізвища як трафімов той же татара
і таке інше вони всі пам'ятають а раптом
знову політика поміняється і знову буде
Центральна вказівка нені пущать якраз в
тому та річ що питання держави щоби була
дотримана ее безпека щоби в часи війни
Росія не могла впливати на Уми і серця
через своїх представників тому Якраз це
питання має бути вирішене на державному
рівні а через марафони і всі інші засоби
от краще владі роз'яснювати для своїх
прихильників чому це питання має бути
вирішена і не ривнувати до того що
європейська Солідарність пропонує
ефективніше рішення а взяти на озброєння
виконати і від цього виграють всі